so that was method one ok now I'm going
to show you another way to do this ok
now it's not immediately obvious but if
you have a look at area shaded in green
I'm going to take my red polka dots and
if you have a look at my area in green
and then I want you to turn your head 90
degrees to the right can you see that
way ok can you see all right you can
create an exact right you see what we've
got here is an area bounded to this axis
in exactly the same way that i had an
area over here battle to this axis has
been turned over that's all ok so
therefore i don't i'm not limited to
necessarily thinking about adjust with
respect to X and that horizontal axis
right you can see this area's kind of
climbing upwards ok so therefore I can
consider it as two areas it's still too
by the way but I can consider them with
relation to the vertical axis ok so
here's the way I'm going to do it
everything I'm about to do is going to
be in terms of the vertical axis so that
means white right this is a function of
X right now so i need to change it so
it's a function of Y ok so I need to
make extra subject right so the first
thing i would do is i would say x cubed
equals y minus 1 you care with that and
then should make x subject well i guess
i would i would say take the cube root
of both sides right but don't forget i'm
about to integrate right that's a
calculus thing i don't want like square
roots eyes on keiran son's my flyer I
want indices right because indices are
easy to deal with when i differentiate
or integrate because it's all to do with
power is right what their size up ok so
now I have this function with respect to
Y that's really good now I can consider
it again instead of X boundaries I'm not
interested in expounder ease anymore
because this is not
exit I'm interested in why boundaries
now you already know one of them is it's
zero I have to consider these areas
differently still why do I have to
consider them separately okay so you
know how sorry I got rid of it you know
how we're looking at this guy right and
I said look at this guy watch out those
are negative Y values so when you add
them all up you'll get a negative area
that's kind of what I really wars right
well this 81 the X values are signed in
the negative do you see that like
negative 1 negative a half that are so
when you add all of those up your cat
am- area okay so therefore when I work
out a one what I want is minus the
integral from all right one of my upper
lower bounds here 0 up to 5 10 to 1 of
this guy this is the function i'm
interested in now going upwards ok so y
minus 1 it's a power third and I'm doing
it with respect to Y so I say dy okay i
guess you can think about it we used to
have our areas like a bunch of these and
they're standing up so DX is horizontal
but now what I'm hanging up is these
things so dy is going to be this
vertical distance ready make sense okay
let's go ahead and integrate minus okay
careful right I push the power up by one
that gives me Y minus one to have four
thirds and then what do I do with that
power I / the new power right so i
divide by four thirds from not to 10 k
divided by four thirds is the same as
multiplying by three quarters now I'm
going to do two things to you first I'm
gonna like those reporters but sick of
me just like when you differentiate
something with a constant coefficient
likes a 15 or like better example three
quarters okay that three-quarters can be
kind of taken out of the equation right
you can take the three quarters out
differentiate the x squared and then
multiply with three quarters back ok so
I'm going to do the same thing with this
recorder I'm going to slap him out the
front okay which leaves me with just
this guy has a thing that needs to be
evaluated at my upper and lower lounge
okay you can do this all the time okay
because all you're going to get is a
common factor of three quarters on your
upper and your lower about so you might
as well take them out of the out of the
road let's evaluate minus three quarters
times what what happens when you
evaluate at one yeah very good you get
zero because it's 1-1 which is zero so
good when I evaluated at 0 I get 0 minus
10 minus 1 negative 1 to the power 4
thirds now I'll just write back because
it's a bit confusing in my head right
I'm going to raise the power for first
so negative 1 power 4 is 1 and then I
take the cube root to deal with that
one-third and that's the one so this
looks to me like negative three quarters
times negative 1 which is well that's
kind of a relief because I've already
worked out this area right it's the same
area remember okay so it's still three
quarters that's good okay now let's try
squeeze it in here another workout a to
now the strength of this method is that
since a 2 is bounded to the y axis right
when i integrate with respect to Y i
don't need to do any of this subtraction
business and just directly give me a
tune ok because it's bounded to the
right axis so i say they're positive x
is so there would be a negative area so
that's good what my batter is one
tonight
but up y minus 1 to the power at third
and I've already worked out with the
preview function is so I'm going to go
ahead I'm even going to take out three
quarters at the front and left with y
minus ones that have four thirds from
one to nine so three quarters factorize
at the front nine minus 1 is 8 so 8 to
the power 4 thirds I'll work that out
the second when I evaluate it out one I
kind of have already done that right so
that's going to be take away 0 yep all
right three quarters times I think I'm
going to do the kid buu first that's
probably a bit easier to deal with right
rather than eight ton de tanto blade so
eight and hubby third is two and then
you do to power 4 which is 16 for 16
that's going to cancel their which gives
me 12 which is a relief because I've
already worked out like this area is
right so now i have a total area just
like i had before and you can see it
confirms we did it right the first time
but which method do you prefer evolution
okay all right now here's what I'm going
to suggest right the first answer to
your question is sure if you want to
nothing's going to stop you because I
consider them as two separate areas so I
can integrate them however I like okay
however I just personally I'm going to
discourage you from doing that because
number one you rather skip confusing
yourself which one am I integrating
which way that's just kind of a risk
secondly do you notice because i
integrate two areas right i end up using
the same integrand sorry saving two
grand which gives me the same primitive
right same same integrand which gives me
the same primitive right now by using
the same method on both parts of the
area I saved my source of work I don't
even need to think about integrating
this cuz I've already done it right
whereas if you had gotten to a two
you've got to do all this work and then
all of this work your change boundaries
I think the advantages start to diminish
so I'm going to encourage you to people
I'm methi big which access you want to
go for right and honestly most of the
questions you get will be very obviously
one axis or the other pick it admin go
for ok top hopefully do execution minus
eight and then integrate that surgeon 2x
cubed minus H so that would be that's
gonna be sure oh so it's gonna be like
this guy right you turn like that yeah
yeah yeah the short answer is yes you
can however I why don't so in case you
didn't quite follow that right we want
this green area right where the green
area another way we can get that green
area is by taking this entire graph and
see how its compared to nine well if you
take the whole thing nine units down
which is way down to here okay then this
area I mean you can even see because of
the awesomeness of my diet again you can
use it the shape and the dimensions of
the area will be identical and sure
enough you should get I mean beyond the
integral we're talking about is negative
because underneath the access from 0 to
2 of what do we just say X cubed minus 8
with respect to X you can go ahead you
can know that my caution with that is
exactly the same way that here I've had
to muck around with things I've had to
think about rectangle and subtract and
then here I've had to muck around with
things I've had to change this function
such a relation to something else and
I've had to get new boundaries from a
song okay every time you use an integral
that's further away from the particular
area that's obviously there you really
have to justify it I'm not entirely sure
how I Woodward this area have is
equivalent to I mean obviously i'd
probably draw a graph and i would say by
translation this a 2 is equivalent to
this and then i would go ahead and
evaluate just for the walls
quickly okay x to the 4 on 4 minus 8x
yeah that looks pretty good let's see
here 16 on for takeaway 16 take away 0
looks like 12 to me right not that i
really like that however just be patient